we're in Austin Texas for the Texas Book
Festival the book TV bus at the Texas
Book Festival this year inside the bus
is Candace Maillard she's the author of
this book the river of doubt thanks for
joining us thank you for having me well
what is this about this is about an
expedition that Theodore Roosevelt took
down an unmapped River in the Amazon in
1914 after he tried and failed to regain
the presidency in 1912 and what what
makes it worth the book you know it's
this extraordinary story of an
exceptional leader but not on the scale
of Nations and armies as we're used to
thinking of Roosevelt but among this
tiny desperate group of men who are
driven to the limits of human endurance
while Roosevelt was on this expedition
he and his men lost nearly all of their
supplies to Rapids one man drown another
man was murdered Rosa became gravely
injured and nearly committed suicide an
attempt to save the other men there also
shadowed and attacked by indigenous
tribesmen and I think it I think it
explains who Roosevelt was as a man we
heard a lot of or chaired a lot of him
as an adventurer and he would go out
west a lot did he go down into this area
very often he didn't this was his first
time and I think you're exactly right he
was not only adventurer he was an
extraordinary naturalist and I think
what's interesting about Rosa if you
look at the entirety of his life there's
a pattern again and again if he faced
hardship or disappointment or sorrow or
loss he would turn to type of heart
adventure as a therapy and he would
choose something as dangerous and as
difficult as he could and when he went
to the Badlands in the West that was
after his mother and his first wife had
died on the same night he did the same
thing when his father died he went to
the backwoods of Maine after he left the
presidency and was mourning the loss of
value went to Africa and after he lost
the election in 1912 he went into the
Amazon where did he go in the Amazon and
what was the route how did how did the
trip happen well he was invited to go on
a speaking tour through South America
and being this great naturalist
lifelong naturalist he thought I will
take this opportunity to go into the
Amazon and go and collecting trips and
he was going to go on a you know and and
a difficult but not particularly
dangerous trip when he got there he was
invited to go down this unmet river
which the man who found its headwaters
had no idea where it went
and so named at the Rio de dieu Buddha
the river of doubt and being Roosevelt
he jumped at the opportunity but they
were completely unprepared for such a
dangerous expedition and is very
different from the one he had originally
planned and then they have a month to
get to the district yet to the river and
they're losing oxen and mules and
provisions and Men so by the time they
even just reach the river before they
even launch their boats they're in real
trouble who are some of the characters
that went within orbit we're organizing
the trip it was an extraordinary group
of men it was Roosevelt of course there
was a second son Kermit who is an
extraordinary young man he was just 24
he already spoke at least half a dozen
languages he had finished Harvard in two
and a half years and he was already
living and working Brazil when Roosevelt
got there and he ends up being the real
hero of the text edition and really
saving his father's life now in the
lives of the other men while Roosevelt
contracted malaria as many of the men
did but he also became gravely injured
he he cut his leg open I'm trying to
free some canoes and developed a deadly
infection and got to the point where he
could barely lift his head
just then the expedition reached these
set of Rapids that were absolutely
impassable everyone believed and they
thought they were going to have to
abandon their canoes and strike that
into the rainforest every man for
himself and Roosevelt you know couldn't
even walk much less fight his way
through the jungle and so he had brought
with him a lethal dose of morphine and
he he didn't want to endanger the lives
of other men so he told his son look you
can get out I'll stay here and his son
Rhapsody wasn't going to let his father
take his own life and so he found a way
he convinced the other men that he could
get these dugouts or 2,500 pound dugout
canoes down these down these Rapids by
my rope and he did and and his father
realized that the best way to save
Kermit's life was
to live himself and so as long as he was
alive [ __ ] would find a way to get him
out of the out of the rain floor had
Kermit become a naturalist a traveler
too or you know criminal was still a
very young man but he had gone to Africa
with his father and and absolutely did
have an interest in Natural History but
his main interest on going on this trip
was to watch out for his father and his
his mother had asked him to do it
what were some of the other some of the
other people who were they there's
George Gary who's an American Naturalist
and he's a guy that the American Museum
of Natural History sent to the Amazon to
watch out for ozone he was this
extraordinary guy he had spent decades
in the rainforests of South America he
had collected tens of thousands of birds
and other animals and he had also gotten
involved in all these local
insurrections he had spent two and a
half years running guns for
revolutionary chief three months in the
South American prison everyday expecting
to be hauled outside and shot so he was
this extraordinary tough ornithologist
and and then there's Colonel Candido
Rondon who was part Indian he was born
during the bloody war the triple
alliances orphan when he was just two
years old but he worked his way up the
Brazilian military became the commander
of the strategic Telegraph Commission
and his job was to string the telegraph
line to the Amazon so he had explored
more than any other man alive but he was
especially devoted to protecting the
Indians making contact with them and
protecting them and it's famous orators
men was die if you must but never kill
and they died right and left and rose
and run down would never let them fight
back what how long was the expedition
the expedition took three months it was
a month to get there over the Brazilian
Highlands and then two months on the
river and it did people in America know
where he was they did Rosalina was an
extraordinary writer and he had and he
had a contract with Scribner as he was
writing articles for them and as they
went along he would send them back
before they got to the river he could
send with runners he could send his
articles and so by the time he was on
the river they were starting to be
published in the United States and and
Edith his wife was starting to
worried because you know there's very
vivid Roosevelt II and descriptions of
piranhas and people dying and and she
thinks here's my son and my husband
going down this river and I won't have
any contact with him for months how did
the expedition end it ended with
Roosevelt sixty-five pounds lighter and
never and not the same man physically
and it was was obvious to everyone that
he would never do anything like this
again three men died as I said one drown
one was murdered and they left the
murderer to certain death in the
rainforest but they achieved something
extraordinary they put a river that was
nearly a thousand miles long on the map
of the world and Roosevelt took great
pride in that he never never regretted
this expedition
even though shortened his life and
that's my next question what did you
then he died Helen just five years later
he was always in and out of hospitals
and he blamed it on his Brazilian
troubles and it certainly did contribute
to the end of his life but you know he
said he he was always happy to pay the
piper for a good dance and he certainly
had one Lissa's how did it impact
Kermit's life well unfortunately Kermit
had a very tragic end he handed up
killing himself when he thirty about
thirty years later Rosa was very close
to his father and they think that Herman
was very close to thought and I think
Roosevelt always directed Kermit Kermit
had a lot of intelligence and passion
and drive but he he it just sort of
unraveled after his father died he said
he wrote to his mother that the bottom
had dropped out for him and and he you
know became an alcoholic and had a very
difficult life and and he was married to
a young woman Belle Willard who was you
know a well-known socialite at that time
and she when FDR became president she
would have FDR send the FBI out to find
him and bring him home and finally she
asked him to find a job for him during
the World War two and he sent him to
Alaska and portioning that's where
Herkimer took his own life why did you
pick this this story well I'm you know I
was working at National Geographic
magazine I've been an editor my right at
over six years of Mayors by
in history and great interest in natural
history in which legend interest in the
Amazon and I heard about the story from
a man named James Chase who wrote a book
called 1912 great book about the
election of 1912 and so I started
researching it and I thought oh my god
this is an extraordinary story I can't
believe that I didn't know anything
about it and and I just sort of he
mildly obsessed with it and and the more
research I did the more I thought I
really wanted to tell the story where
did you do the research I did the
research at the Library of Congress but
the presidential papers at the theater
Roosevelt collection at Harvard at the
American Museum of Natural History
especially in the ornithology Department
and they spent a month in Brazil a
couple weeks in Rio and then two weeks
on this River which is still incredibly
remote you have to you have to rent a
small plane and fly for hours over
absolutely unbroken jungle from Horizon
to Horizon but incredibly beautiful and
pristine this is your first book my
first book what was the experience like
it was extraordinary it really was I
love researching at uni and I and I
missed these men and I people enjoy
reading it
this was a best-seller in how was it a
best-seller it was on on the New York
Times list it was a notable book of the
year in your times and yo say today and
Washington Post and a few other
newspapers as well and yeah it's in well
what now you know I have some ideas I
haven't committed to anything I think
the idea is really 90% of it and I was
so spoiled with this book I had so much
work with and especially the Amazon
itself you know the Amazon became a
character in this book and I wanted to
know how these men these great hunters
and these great explorers could go there
and nearly starve and it's amazing you
get you go to the Amazon you understand
right away because absolutely silent
everything is so good at either being a
predator or not being prey and you just
can't find them and and it's just a
fascinating story of evolution the book
is called the river of doubt Theodore
Roosevelt's darkest journey and the
author is
Candace to Milan thank you very much
thank you honey